so another 10 shorts these ones uh
specifically about philosophical topics
covering a wide range some on particular
thinkers um
posing some challenges to me so here you
go
so i think it's kind of fitting that i
start this one with a question about
tens so mark smith asked me
what are your 10 favorite philosophers
and why do you enjoy them
so i was asked a question like this
recently at a speaking gig that i did
and
it was it was put to me something like
uh you're on the desert island who who
are you going to take along
and um
this is more or less the list i came up
with so among the ancients plato
aristotle epictetus
and then uh
medievals for me it's always going to be
ansem
i've got quite a few people in the
modern and late modern era so hegel
kierkegaard nietzsche
uh but i also really like descartes and
then there's two french catholic
thinkers from the 20th century who i
picture particularly
enjoy reading and thinking through and
that's maurice blondel
and gabriel marcel
now
why do i enjoy them it really depends on
the particular philosopher i enjoy
different things about them
aristotle you know i enjoy seeing how
all the parts sort of fit together as
you read across the corpus and and i
like his point of view on things
epictetus it's kind of similar but we
don't have quite as much stuff by him
plato i love you know the way he he
writes and the the problems he poses and
i'm kind of a platonist at heart in a
lot of respects um it's probably why i
like anselm and and maurice blondell so
much as well
hegel is is um you know with hegel and
blown down they're both these
dialectical thinkers who try to
encompass everything they think that
philosophy has a task to
take in the totality and make sense out
of things
and i really like that i like the way
that they they did it i agree with
blondel more than i do hegel
um kierkegaard and marcel are kind of in
the same boat with each other they're
non-systematic thinkers who are at the
same time
pretty rigorous
and of course you know nietzsche
is nietzsche same with
descartes so here's a great question by
james paris do you consider economic
writers as philosophers like keynes
versus hayek and so the question is
whether
i consider them you know sufficiently
reflective sufficiently
i don't know what you would say deep to
be to be philosophers
and i would say yeah a lot of a lot of
economists i mean political economy used
to be part of philosophy
adam smith did not think of himself as
an economist but as a as a moral
philosopher
and you know whether it's keynes or
hayek or gailbraith you know really
anybody who's doing that kind of
high-level stuff
they're they're going into philosophy
and they might be doing crappy
philosophy or they might be doing good
philosophy a lot of that depends on how
how well they actually understand their
own activities and i would say the same
thing goes for sociology you know is
is david riesman and thorstein veblen
are they are they philosophers max weber
are they philosophers or are they
sociologists you know um eric michels
people like that well they're kind of
both it's okay to straddle different um
different uh
boundaries that way
a lot of philosophy is actually done
outside of philosophy departments in
part because of
what's happened to philosophy in the
last 100 years which
really shrunk it's its purview
in analytic and i would even say in
continental philosophy apart from its
its classical perspective
um
so you know in in poli sci and economics
and
psychology and literature history
there's a lot of people who are doing
philosophy and not necessarily calling
it philosophy
on the other hand in those disciplines
if you start asking philosophical
questions they may kick you out and
suggest you go over to the philosophers
so uh this one comes from the fates have
warned says got another question this
one is on general metaphysics
why do you think there's such an
animosity towards teleology and
philosophy since the modern era i can
only think of a few major philosophers
and stakehart off the top of my head
that are sympathetic to it
um
so that's a complicated question and
here's a few scattered bits that that
maybe supply a bit of an answer
so first off um
you know
teleological explanations were somewhat
overdone by by scholastic and and other
thinkers who just weren't doing
some of them weren't doing a very good
job at uh at philosophy and they were
they were using it to sort of fill in in
gaps and things and really
less
answer questions than just banish them
and so there was like bad geologic
teleological thinking and that's what
the early moderns were really reacting
against later on people like leibniz
will say
you guys went too far we need to bring
back in some of these teleological
notions and some of the other notions
like substantial forms
that you guys were too quick to throw
away
um and you know i mean it comes in it
comes back in definitely with people
like like hegel
um
so i i you know i would say that there
is some
there's still some teleological thinking
going on but if you want your teleology
to do any real work
you have to constantly rethink it you
have to figure out what actually can be
given
legitimate teleological explanations
that can be often quite complicated
and what things are not susceptible what
things are better explained with with
other modes of explanation so you don't
want to try to use it to cover
everything
maybe that answers the question
so mark smith has a good good challenge
here for me uh you often talk about
philosophers being top tier thinkers or
not being so
what for you qualify someone as a
first-rate philosopher so to speak or
instead as a second-rate thinker
um and i don't have a simple answer for
that you know i'm tempted to say well
you know i just say so but that's that's
not really the case
um there's going to be some element of
subjectivity to this and
because of the kind of work that i do
you know is
basically a historically informed
philosopher
who takes seriously the notion that you
you really need to like work out what a
philosopher is doing in general and then
locate them in relation to other
people's projects
a lot of people aren't going to share my
views on this like i would consider and
this will probably be anathema for some
people i would say that that you know
uh bertrand russell is a second rate
thinker i would actually say that roland
bart is a second rate thinker in
continental philosophy i would say that
um you know when we when we after you
work in the field for a while you kind
of get a sense of who really has some
some major contributions to make
and who's like a one-trick pony or who
can't really take in into account other
people's
views on things and has to treat them in
very reductive ways whose histories of
philosophy are
pretty much ideological crap
who is very schematic in what they do
those are what make people second rate
are you going to get a ton of mileage
out of thinking the world thinking
the self thinking the other thinking
about you know
origins and god and all the the great
classic philosophical topics out of this
thinker that's part of what makes them
first rate but i would say another thing
that's important for me at least is that
they actually have some conception
of
what's going on in other people's works
so it's hard to be a really good thinker
in isolation in brilliant isolation as
we might say
great question by zero she flies
what are your views on human
perfectibility in the moral domain is
there such a thing as real moral
progress and how do we tell
this is probably not going to be a
satisfying answer to many people
human perfectability
do we mean perfectability as in like
reaching the end point through our own
efforts
in a purely imminent process
if that's the case then i say no
i think that we are radically damaged
and if you want to look at this in a
christian context you can talk about
original sin which is not by the way you
know just some some doctrine that covers
over everything or you know a starting
point for arguments but rather it's um
it's a problem it's a call to actually
like think things out like marcel says
it's a mystery
that said is it possible to make moral
progress
i think so
how do we tell when somebody's making
moral progress there's not one single
criteria that we can appeal to
and it's a lot easier at the lower
levels i think to say well you're no
longer killing your neighbor and
screwing your neighbor's you know spouse
and cheating everybody you know that's
that's some progress
that's that's
a lot easier than getting into the the
harder
uh stuff about where we really make
progress you know um
but i do think that moral progress is
possible i've seen it happen
not as much in myself as i'd like to say
it's been more observing others
um
but yeah i think there is there is real
moral progress now is there real moral
progress as individuals or you know as
cultures or as societies that's a that's
a larger and different question
and do we need some sort of connection
to something transcending us to fill in
the all the gaps and holes and lacuna in
ourselves
i would say yes to that but that's also
a different question
so gerald sword uh mentioning uh i think
one of my first videos in the half hour
hegel series
says uh you discuss the negation of the
object is there any way to make sense of
sart's ontological categories of being
in itself and being for itself through
the negation of the object since
consciousness relates to objects as
subject and to itself as both subject
and object
well yes and no
for sartre you're not really
negating the object uh so much
the object is in itself and it stays in
itself whether you negate it or like it
or don't like it
it's what it is you know
this is a piece of paper and that's
that's it
um
you yourself as a subject are a negation
or a negativity or you know a hole in
being or however you want to put it
who is able to engage in you know
negation and knee hilation but that
that's reflexive that's being for itself
and by the way you know whatever i
happen to say about hegel at one point
in this series that's going to take me
two years to complete
um that's not all of hegel that's only a
little bit of hegel and you gotta you
gotta fuse it all together sarda's
taking some some of his categories from
from hegel um
but what sartre is doing is is uh in
many respects more crude than than what
hegel's doing and more
uh
there's not a lot of you know growth or
process going on insert the for itself
which is what you are
that means that your pure negativity
unless you decide to you know nail
yourself down in some way which never
really works for sartre
and objectify yourself as in itself
you don't really have
determinancy
and sard also sees relations with the
others both of us trying to do that to
each other
so another view asks a question which
i've been asked in in some of my earlier
vu videos um what do you think about
race
is there such a thing as as a pure race
or is race a myth
so
is there such a thing as a pure race no
i mean if if race is supposed to
correspond to
genetic pools of things we know that
there's tons of genetic variability
and that a lot of the things that we
call races aren't really races all you
really need to do to figure out that
that races as we construct them
sociologically
are rather arbitrary is go from country
to country
and you'll find that people who you know
in the united states we have this this
one drop rule you know you're you're
considered african-american or black or
however you want to put it if you have
any uh black ancestry
and
go to africa and see if they think that
you're black
it's not going to happen because they
they parse out things differently
um then you know then go to brazil and
see that the gradations are very
different go to haiti and see that you
know the the degree actually matters and
we could do this for all sorts of other
things too there's no such thing as a
white race there's no such thing as a
yellow race a black race a red race
they're all you know interfused and
and mixtures of things and we do have
you know some some genetic uh
pools but they tend not to to coincide
so neatly with with the traditional
conceptions of race
um
is it a myth yeah it's a myth in the
sense of of being
like stories that we tell ourselves
but i mean race does have effects within
areas because people have treated each
other differently because of racial
differentiation
so
if you want to say it's a myth that
doesn't mean that like we then say oh
well we're all i'm colorblind i can't
see anything
you got to acknowledge that that race
has you know had some some pretty
important effects but it's not based in
anything truly real
so here's a a good follow-up to this
this question on race without even
really realizing it's by christopher
dunn
what are your thoughts on john locke's
idea of real essence
i gotta admit it's not something i i
spend a lot of time thinking about
i don't do a lot of reading or writing
onlock
at least in the last 10 years i've got a
few papers laying around that i i wrote
back a while ago and need to actually
like send out but i haven't done a lot
of new work
thinking in his categories and when we
talk about locke's real essence we need
to distinguish it against locks notion
of nominal essence so the real essence
would be
what you know what really makes a thing
what it is so for physical things like
for example this paper
um you know these names on it um what
makes the paper what it is the substance
you know and the qualities that it has
and the way it's put together and all
that
um
what what produces the effects on us
that's that's its real essence and um
then there's the nominal essence and
that's you know our conception
of what it is and we get things right
with physical things when the real
essence corresponds to nominal essence
lock has a kind of weird idea that it's
it works the same way he tries to
transpose this into the realm of
morality without not a hell of a lot of
success his moral theory is kind of a
mess
it's really interesting stuff don't get
me wrong i love things that are that are
philosophical messes but it's it's um
it's hard to
really
um
make it make it adequately plausible to
other people
um but it's it is based on this notion
that there are real essences out there
for
for moral things and then we can you
know we can come to
have a conception of it that a nominal
essence that actually corresponds to it
it makes
maybe makes a little bit more sense with
mathematics which is another thing that
he thinks has has that same uh thing so
i don't know if that helps you but
that's my idea about it
so gerald sword asks
what if any is the relation between
nietzsche's master slave morality and
hegel's master slave dynamic was
nietzsche trying to correct hegel i
don't think so
they're doing different things in their
discussion of this
nietzsche's not talking about a master
slave morality he talks about master
morality slave morality and the gulf
between them and how radically different
they are in slave morality as a radical
trans valuation of
values
with hegel it's it's the the master
slave or lordship and bondage people get
worked up or you should translate it
this way but it does translate to master
and slave hair shaft and connect theft
um
it's a dialectic
so
the master gets to
to exist for his own sake the slave
exists for the sake of the master and it
looks like the master has won because
the master gets to enjoy
reality through the mediation of the
slave but
the laugh is on him because the slave is
the one who who now develops and the
master is just kind of
dialectically done
so
they're doing different things i mean
is nietzsche trying to correct hegel on
this i don't even think they're in the
same ballpark really
um
hegel is going to go hegel for hickle
this is going to be a tiny bit people
make a lot of hay out of the master
slave dialectic
but what's really important is what
follows after it um
you know the shapes of unhappy
consciousness
and then all the other things that are
that are going on
so i i don't see nietzsche's sort of
trying to correct hegel on this
so last one by gerald sword
one could argue from hegel that the
relation between master and slaves is
justified as it is the slaves who
develop and grow in the end this could
justify cruelty and oppression and he
has examples like black slavery produced
art forms like gospel blues or jazz
music
arguably self-reflective and
self-conscious music how can we escape
from the justification for cruelty that
seems to arise from hegel hegel doesn't
justify cruelty with the master slave
dialectic
that's not the point of it it's to trace
out um sort of the beginnings of things
and it's not supposed to be
like a justification for how society
ought to be across the board
it's not even meant to be a suggestion
about what's going on in in all society
at any given given point in time
i think a lot of people read too much
into the master slave dialectic in part
because they're not reading the rest of
the phenomenology or the rest of hegel's
works
hegel is not suggesting
that
you know
there's a sort of theodicy to to the
master slave dialectic
um he fully understands that like he
says you know history is a slaughter
bench
uh and and lots and lots of
terrible things have to happen along the
way to to people
um
do good things come out of it yeah i
mean it's not as if
in the case that we're talking about
here that the cruelty and oppression
leads to the slaves producing these art
forms for the masters because remember
in the master slave dialectic the slave
is working on objects providing them to
the master
and you know
is it really the case that that gospel
blues and jazz music
are um more self-reflective and
self-conscious than other forms of
music i don't think so um i think that i
don't i don't even think that you can
say that that they're uniformly so i
think some
some composers probably a lot more some
perhaps less so
in any case i don't see just sort of
justifying cruelty and oppression
in that sort of way